après six mois à gatineau cette
infirmière d'origine française voit des
avantages à travailler au québec peu
plus de reconnaissance j'ai pas si je
peux dire ça comme ça un peu plus de
responsabilités un peu partout au québec
on souhaite multiplier l'embauchent deux
françaises comme ludivine guillaud
présentement on estime qu'on pourrait
embaucher 150 infirmiers pour répondre à
nos besoins
c'est qu'on ne formeraient simplement
plus au sud et fermiers et et firent
mien mais c'est sûr qu'on travaille
beaucoup avec nos maisons d'enseignement
de la région mais vraisemblement le
bassin de main d'oeuvre n'est pas
suffisant pour répondre à nos besoins
un problème qui existe dans plusieurs
régions dans les inscriptions maison
enseignement faut trouver des
alternatives puis le recrutement à
l'international en fait partie quatorze
établissements québécois partent à paris
en décembre pour recruter ils sont deux
fois plus nombreux qu'au printemps
dernier et veulent tripler le nombre de
recrues au total on souhaite embaucher
333 infirmiers et infirmières de
l'étranger par exemple montréal veut en
recruter 157 la montérégie 70 laval 44
et québec veut engager 26 français et
françaises
c'est une des solutions là pour nous
aider
à faire face à la pénurie de
main-d'oeuvre la plus grande pénurie
qu'on au québec c'est une pénurie de
conditions de travail
la fiq estime qu'avant de recruter il
faut voir s'il ya vraiment pénurie
plusieurs infirmières d'ici chercherait
toujours des postes à temps plein ces
infirmières et infirmiers qui vont venir
ici je souhaite qu'il soit heureux je
sais pas ce qu'on leur promet mais
actuellement c'est difficile parce que
mes proches les propres professionnelle
dans le réseau au québec on la
difficulté à rester en emploi
elles sont essoufflés elles sont en
surcharge de la détresse leurs
conditions de travail sont difficiles
ludivine qui osent comprend que la
pratique au québec n'est pas un conte de
fées des fois c'est c'est un petit peu
dur au niveau 2 du nombre de patients
qu'on a par infirmière ici david
gêne-t-il et réseaux canada montréal